[Applause]
good evening ladies and gentlemen
friends and colleagues
welcome to the scientific and technical
Awards before we begin I'd like to take
a moment to acknowledge the entire
scientific and technical awards
committee
it's subcommittees and all the
surrogates who research and recommend
these awards these are men and women
from around the world who represent a
diverse spectrum of technical and
filmmaking skills including
cinematography digital imaging sound
production theatrical projection film
and laboratory processes lighting and
stage equipment mechanical or optical
effects virtual production
pre-visualization and editing we are
fortunate to have their dedication and
service which is entirely voluntary
this year the committee's initial review
totaled 72 submissions launching
investigations into 11 separate areas of
technology the amount of work that goes
into this process is astounding and the
fact that our volunteers take time out
of their busy lives is a testament to
their passion towards the advancement of
the art and science of motion pictures
many of these committee participants
have traveled a long way to join us here
tonight could those members of the main
committee the subcommittee's and all the
surrogates and all who participated in
the research and reports please stand
thank you
[Music]
we all thank you for the hundreds of
hours spent this year getting to this
evening tonight is part of the Academy's
celebration of 90 years of the Oscars so
we're adding something special this
evening as you are probably aware
tonight's award recipients are wearing
red boutonnieres
in addition previously awarded Gordon E
Sawyer and Oscar recipients and John a
Bonner metella commendation honorees are
wearing a white boutonniere these are
the elder statesmen of motion picture
science and our honored guests this
evening gentlemen would you please stand
[Applause]
the Academy's scientific and technical
awards are unique and that they cover
accomplishments that may take a decade
or more of invention refinement
engineering and evolution this evening
is an event that is special in the
industry it is a way for us to
acknowledge the deep appreciation and
respect that we have for the significant
technical contributions to our industry
I know that for some of you the
recognition being bestowed tonight is
honoring the culmination of a lifetime
of effort it has been a privilege to
chair this year's investigations and I
want to extend my congratulations to
everyone being honored here tonight the
show will start soon so sit back and
enjoy the evening thank you very much
[Applause]